break down for me hr1 i've read a bit of
it there are some things that actually
like but there are some
really alarming things it's incredibly
alarming because hr1 nationalizes
elections you talk about nationalized
production and
confiscation of property what hr one
does is takes elections away from the
states it says that
all across the united states of america
there will be universal mail and ballots
it says that there will be no voter
registration reviews anywhere in the
united states of america
no picture id for voting in the united
states of america felons can vote
there will be same-day voter
registration and voting
there will be online voter registration
and it sets up an
independent commission for redistricting
states right now do their own
redistricting why do the democrats want
to take over redistricting
because republicans control 62 of 99
legislative bodies across the united
states of america
so the republicans are control of the
political reshaping for the next 10
years
of the respective states the democrats
don't like that so
h.r 1 is completely unconstitutional
in every way shape form or fashion now
of course the democrats are going to
throw some nice things in there to try
to
you know entice you to do and they're
going to give it a real nice name for
the people's act
but it is an oxymoronic title with the
emphasis on the word [ __ ]
because what it does it takes away the
ability of states
to run their elections what good stuff
did they put in it
i hadn't seen any really well uh i'm in
favor of felons being able to
have the right to vote oh yeah you
mentioned that it sounds like you viewed
as a negative i
i look you know i think it was uh
don't do the don't do the crime if you
can't do the time remember sammy davis
jr saying that for the you know serpico
uh there has to be consequences and
ramifications for the
you know i mean the way i see it is
there there's there's two really big
things for me when it comes to felons
if you commit a crime and then you are
you know
you're handed down some kind of
punishment penalty or something from a
judge
you serve your time for the crime your
rights should be restored your right to
own a gun and your right to vote in my
opinion so should a rapist be able to
own a gun and vote
i think the answer is yes after they've
paid their their debt
i can't go there well what if what if
they started i got two daughters so i
can't go there but so you and i are
going to disagree on that one
respect because first of all you know if
you if you did that to
my daughter you got to deal with me
right okay
yeah there's there's certain things but
you know beyond the courts
and again i don't like the blanket one
size fits all
you know if you want to look at certain
offenses
where if someone does their time then
they are restored i agree with but to
make the blanket statement
i can't and it's state by state right
now right like in some states felons can
vote
or yeah i think that virginia is one of
those states that
and i think there's a reason why i think
i think that's actually a really good
point i think there's probably some
crimes where you do not get your rights
restored you know so
we had a conversation the other day
about the second amendment
and i said if the constitution says your
right to keep in barium should not be
infringed
there's no caveats in that it doesn't
say if you're a felon
so as far as i i can as far as i see it
i mean while you're in prison
or on probation or on parole whatever it
is you are serving punishment you can't
have a gun but i think once you've paid
your debt to society your rights should
be restored well again
and and i would say that if you're a
person that went out and committed every
aggravated assault you know if you
committed a a gun related crime
i don't know if i want you to come back
and get or spouse abuse or something
like that
but let's let's talk you know it's a
good point that you do i think it's
funny that i might be further right on
2a than you
i don't think so i'm on the board of the
national association but
but you talk about hr 8 which is another
thing that just passed
the united states house of
representatives and so think about what
hra does
let's say you got a friend that
you know is is waiting to get a firearm
but they just had someone break into
their house and you want to
you know hey here's my you know p365
sig or here's my glock 43. do you know
that you're now a felon
because of what was just passed well so
it didn't pass the senate yet though
right no but it's passed in the house
right and so again you know we got to
understand
when we say i hadn't passed the senate
but what we have to start thinking about
what is the mentality what is the
philosophy of
governance of the progressive socialists
left because that's
what you see happening in the house of
representatives
h.r 127 h.r 130. i know that you got
firearms here
but do you know that sheila jackson lee
says that you cannot have any loaded
firearms in your house
what that's hr1 what's the point of
having it
well i'm sorry i mean i'm the government
yeah
i know better than you what's uh did it
pass the house 130.
hr 127 hr 130 have not come up hr 8
was passed hrh and so this bans the
private it effectively bans the private
sale of firearms because
you would need a federal background
check no matter what so there are
certain places where
i'm sorry that makes literally no sense
they like to call it the gun show
loophole
but it's literally not a loophole it's
just the private sale so let's put it
away
there are certain many states that allow
the private transfer because it makes
sense if you live in
west virginia is a good example the
middle of nowhere in west virginia in
the mountains
and you got a neighbor who's you know
maybe two miles down the road
and he's like look man we're getting
really bad
30 to 50 feral hugs and you're like well
why don't i sell you
this here you know firearm so you can
keep your property safe
help keep your kids safe and your crops
or whatever or even i'll loan it to you
oh yeah you can't do that either you
can't do that either that's a felony
right now you can in west virginia
so long as you're not giving it to
someone who is ineligible
so there is still a responsibility on
you if you're like here i'm going to you
know lend you this rifle and it turns
out the guy's a felon now you're in
trouble
i'm going to sell it to you but now
under hr8
you would have to go to an ffl and then
do
the the what is it with the next
background check for the individual
thing 44 73
right and then go through a standard
transfer now me personally
i don't live out in the middle of
nowhere so i don't think
if i was going to do a transfer i'd go
to an ffl anyway just so it's a clean
transfer and my name's off of it
but i certainly understand why there
might be a guy who's like
for his brother i'm gonna give you this
weapon to guard you know the you know
your property or the the five acres in
the back i'm letting you use hr rate
would make that illegal
yeah so it's it's it's make you a felon
yeah
that's messed up like maybe like even if
maybe it could be reasonable if it was
like an administrative fine of some sort
yeah but
but not even that but think about this
okay when my uh my oldest daughter
was going to southern methodist
university she was getting her master's
in biochemistry and hamahama because
she's really smart like a mom
so she had to stay late at night to do
you know lab experiments
lab works whatever and so smu is located
close to downtown dallas and so i loaned
her my nine millimeter
said keep it you know so that when
you're walking out to
your car in parking lot you just make
sure that you're safe hr8 makes me a
felon
for saying to my daughter here take the
ass nine millimeter
so that you can be safe when you're when
you're over there late at night
and i think your your daughter knows how
to use a nine millimeter my daughter has
fired a barrett
okay she's daddy's girl both of them
and so 50 bmgs yeah and so this is my
concern
and again this is why i'm so glad to be
here with young people is that
you are seeing a slow usurpation
confiscation
of your rights by people that have a
mentality
of a philosophy of governance that has
never done
anything to promote freedom you
mentioned earlier
uh term limits i'm a huge advocate for
that yeah 12 years
how would you say 12 years okay how
would we do that this is how you do well
i mean they're not going to vote for it
themselves okay and so that's why
the founding fathers were brilliant it
was almost as if when they sat down 200
and some odd years ago
and wrote the constitution they said how
can these stupid idiots
screw it up and so they figure out every
single
fail-safe back door method and so
therefore they came up with article five
which is a convention of states not a
constitutional convention a convention
of states
whereby if you get 34 states and they
assigned delegates
they can come and they can recommend an
amendment to the constitution
like term limits on federal house of
representatives and senators but if you
get 38 states states can actually change
the constitution states can amend the
constitution that's article 5.
so one of the things that you should
look at is why these guys stand up here
forever
you know you know there are certain
states out there to have term limits on
their state house members
state senators everything's working fine
so if you have 12 years
up here and i base that on two terms of
the senator that's 12 years
six terms in the house of
representatives that's 12 years and it's
not transferable
you don't get to say well you know i've
been over here for 10 years in the house
and now i'm going to run for senator
and i'll get another 12 years no it's 12
years total so we need 36 states
um 34 states 34 states and you can
recommend
an amendment to the cost and then the
senate would have to yeah the house is
senator which they vote on
so we need 38 38 and do we need a
majority in each state just 51 percent
no 38 states to to come together and and
vote to have the participant in an
article five constitution states
theoretically that that kind of
convention that's just the legislative
bodies that's just the legislative bias
right now i think we're at 16. okay for
for republican states
now the republicans control the majority
legislatures but right now we're at 16.
wow well so let me i can loot this back
into the gun control thing because you
mentioned
they could recommend an amendment to the
constitution at 38 they can get it
second amendment says the right to keep
and bear arms shall not be infringed
but in new jersey if you bear arms you
will be arrested and you'll be a felon
yeah in new york and in illinois in
california
your right to keep and bear arms has
been infringed
quite literally as worse as bad as it
could be and guess what that comes back
to exactly what i said
law-abiding constitutional states
that's why i talked about in that
article constitutionalist
versus secessionists the people that are
going against our constitution
they're the secessionists so when you
look at a state that is telling you
that you cannot have your constitutional
right i don't understand why anyone in
any state will sit back and say
well okay you don't get to give it and
take it just the same as you cannot tell
me as a private business owner
i must shut down my business there was a
a post on the donald forum
they change their name it's patriots.win
now where they were talking about
the right to keep and bear arms has been
infringed and there was there was a lot
of sentiment saying
ammunition magazines all that stuff and
so
a lot of the sentiment i found to be
i'll just put it this way uh i won't i
won't comment my opinion but people were
saying
then express your right to bear arms and
and gra and gain judicial standing to
sue
in defense of the second amendment
absolutely that's a bold statement
but think about it but but there are two
cases dc versus heller
uh richard heller and i know him
personally the
you know was afraid he just wanted to be
able to have a firearm to defend himself
in washington d.c they told him he
couldn't do it
he went to the supreme court he won the
case otis mcdonald
black man chicago took on the city of
chicago mcdonald's versus chicago
that was that was relatively recent
wasn't it that was back in the
80s yeah back in the 80s but a black man
just wanted to be able to defend himself
in his home and he took the city of
chicago to the supreme court so it's
already been done
it's already been taken so we have
proven that it it has standing
across the the united states as standing
in states and local municipalities but
yet we still allow
people to undermine the most important
right that you have because the founding
fathers understood
that your first amendment rights the
freedom of speech press expression
you know symbol freedom of religion
petitioned the government for rejection
grievances
those are passive rights if you don't
have a mechanism
to defend and secure those rights
they're going to get taken away from you
and that's why they have the second
amendment the great modern thinker
dave chappelle said the second amendment
is just there in case the first one
doesn't work out
he's absolutely right has an amazing
statement dave chappelle is amazing but
it's absolutely right brilliant
and you think about there have been only
two
instances in the united states america
of revolution
okay uh and that was the american
revolution and
in texas and both of those revolutions
started
because of what gun control gun control
the british were marching toward concord
massachusetts to destroy weapons and
armaments factory
on april the 19th of 1775
they were met at lexington green because
they understood if you're armed your
citizen if you're disarmed you're
subject
october the 2nd 1835 in gonzales texas
the mexican cavalry shows up
because they want a cannon back that
they had given to the people of gonzales
to protect themselves against the
comanche raiders
because they were hearing about this
thing called a revolution amongst the
texans
the texans replied with that famous
response come and take it
wow those are the only two instances
and so this is i'm just all you leftists
that are out there
this is a very bad thing that you all
are doing
well so hold on the the far left they're
super pro 2a
it's the establishment suburban liberal
types
they're so the larger portion of the
left voter the democrat voter
absolutely in favor of gun control but
that element of progressives the
socialist types
i mean they're armed to the teeth they
might not be as nearly as skilled or
well trained or physically fit
but you can see it on twitter they're
advocating yeah that's kind of like the
guy that was part of an
antifa black class matter uh rally down
in austin texas and he had a i think an
ak-47 he went up to a car and started
shaking his ak-47 and inside the car
was an army soldier that's right and he
popped him yep
so look they absolutely
are in favor of guns but again they
don't seem to be as well trained
there are some groups that are there are
there are left-wing socialist and
communist militia types
where you can tell these guys have real
training but they are few and far
between yeah
but if you go to your average antifa
person oh they're they're all about
weapons
i mean they show up with explosives they
show up with guns in portland
and lasers and lasers yeah but we
recently had there was a story of a
woman who was in portland during the
riots she had a she had i think she had
a glock 17.
they want guns you had that guy um what
was the guy who went to the ice facility
in tacoma
oh yeah willem uh yeah that's bronson
yeah he he he had himself a a ghost uh a
ghost gun
that he brought and was using against an
ice facility these are leftists this guy
was a vowed antifa
but see the thing is that and and you
you delve into another subject
is that what antifa black lives matter
does
it's going to be acceptable but if you
have the
the the constitutionalists the
law-abiding legal gun owner
those are the people that the other side
does not want to have
the firearms and so there's a hypocrisy
in that
uh regardless and i think that is the
danger that we see
there was a sorry the military
perspective if you were looking at this
like a combat situation would you then
infiltrate the black lives matter antifa
segment
so that you could utilize it to
overthrow or propagate your victory well
i mean that's one of the forms of
maneuvers infiltration but
we already know who they are we already
know what their structure is i mean
look at the the silliness of the fact
that you know
facebook twitter and all these other
guys they want to kick you know
conservatives off of these platforms but
yet antifa black lives matter
they're still operating on these
platforms i mean the the iranian
mullah over there uh ayatollah khamenei
is still operating on twitter
so again we know everything about them
it's so interesting is that
all of these folks that were
participating in january the 6th
their houses are getting raided they're
being picked up just like that being
arrested
all of these folks that we see over a
year or more
that have been doing these you know
attacks raids and continue to do so
nobody's arresting them thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this
channel youtube.com tim cast irl
monday through friday at 8pm where you
can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you